you know it's no secret that i'm not a
very big fan of public school you may
have heard me mention that a time or two
i don't know
uh but it's important to remember that
the problems with the public school
system are only partially caused by the
fact that the government runs the
institution i mean sure our government
is an incompetent inefficient meandering
morally bankrupt behemoth monstrosity
and tossing your children into its mouth
is a bit like uh what was it jabba the
hutt feeding prisoners into the the
sarlacc i think it was called you don't
get star wars references from me very
often so please appreciate them when
they come but many parents make the
mistake of thinking that all of the
education systems almost literal
pitfalls can be avoided just by avoiding
the great chunk of that system which is
run by the state and so they simply
shuffle their children off to private
school and believe that the problem has
been solved
unfortunately it's rarely that simple
because the other great problem with
public school aside from those issues
that can be linked directly to the
government
is that it is a product of the culture
and the culture is also a product of it
so it's one big circle a snake eating
its tail but this often applies to
private school just as much as public
moreover in both cases whether private
or public your child's mental and moral
formation is being outsourced to
strangers to adults you don't know
now it's possible to find private
schools that are not that are not
products of the greater culture and
which are run and staffed by adults that
you can actually trust to handle the
precious task of educating your kids
but the preponderance of private schools
do not fall into that category
and this report from breitbart i think
shows that pretty well so here's the
report published yesterday it says
private schools across the country are
training teachers to expose kids as
young as four years old to sexually
explicit content in secrecy and without
parents knowledge directed by the
national association of independent
schools nais as part of a queer
inclusive curriculum breitbart news has
reviewed an extensive trove of nin nais
documents and teacher training supplied
to private schools nationwide which
under the guise of being queer and lgbtq
plus inclusive
urge the use of graphic sexual material
in classes starting at pre-k
so breitbart apparently got its hands on
uh
mainly this training workshop
presentation at a major nais conference
in philadelphia a year or two ago it's
an hour long and speakers instruct the
assembled on how to talk to kids as
young as four years old about sex and
gender identity so we'll go through this
here's one clip from an unnamed
presenter
explaining what kids in pre-k should be
told
with the younger children starting in
pre-k
we talk about their bodies about the
parts that they were born with
about penises and vaginas and whether
that makes somebody a boy or a girl
but also their feelings
what do they feel like inside do they
feel like a boy or a girl what does
their head say does their head and their
heart and their body match up
now to emphasize again this is pre-k
typical age for pre-k is four years old
kids at four have only been speaking in
complete sentences for you know a year
and a half or two years
most of them probably have been potty
trained for a year at most maybe less
still can't tie their shoes
and already they're being introduced to
gender ideology at a time when they
could not possibly be expected to notice
how incoherent it is
because a four-year-old isn't gonna
raise his hand and say yes mrs smith uh
the claim that a person can be a male
physically and yet a female in some
ambiguous spiritual sense strikes me as
the strangest and most schizophrenic
form of mind-body dualism and is at best
a religious conviction which has no
place in a curriculum ostensibly based
in science
now even the smartest four-year-old
isn't going to say that they're just
going to sit and nod their heads or
stare blankly as the seeds of insanity
are planted in their helpless minds
well one thing i can tell you as a
four-star chef myself um amateur chef
but i consider myself a four-star chef
your kitchen is not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami kota kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikota also uses
steel source for mills in japan and each
blade is crafted using techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash wood
box and makes sure the knife is stored
safely as well each camaco knife goes
through a rigorous 19-step process that
takes several years from start to finish
to complete our expert blade smiths
forge and shape raw steel into hardy
blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected kamikoto is so
confident that their knives will work
for you that each knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge kamikoto knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge you
just can't get with other knives they
can cut through your rib eye like butter
that is guaranteed uh kamikoto is
currently having a massive extended new
year sale and on top of that sale you
can get an additional 50 50 off any
purchase you make with discount code
matt walsh so click the link below or go
to kamikoda.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh to save an extra 50
today
now in another clip a different
presenter laughs about a time when she
accidentally quote unquote showed
graphic images to a room full of young
children listen
there are missteps where we have to take
a step back and refine i'm going to
share one of my missteps
when i started my first year teaching
with the health and wellness team i had
been given a title to a book so i went
to our school library to pull it and i
pulled it thinking i had the right one i
didn't
and i read through i'm like this is
really progressive stuff but it was my
first year so i'm like okay we're just
super progressive so i went in there
guns blazing and i just went for it and
i ended up talking about the vulva and
the labia with pre-cares and it was just
one of those moments everybody's looking
in [ __ ] and i'm like oh no i made a
really big mistake
and i share that with you because it's
not perfect right it's a practice so be
kind to yourselves when you're like
delving into this
yes be be kind to yourselves as groomers
and predators just a bit of a silly
slapstick comedy there she exposed young
children to sexual content that even she
knew was inappropriate isn't that
hilarious
maybe she could tell that story at the
next pedophiles anonymous meeting and
get a good laugh
now the children she says are like
sexual lab rats basically you can try
different things it's a practice
trial and error type of thing
notice something the parents are not
mentioned
at any point in any of these clips
there is not even lip service paid to
the idea that the parent should have a
say in whether their kids are exposed to
this content they're not even worried
about it it doesn't come up
moving to another clip we're now told
what the second grade lesson plan is
like now
we we have we have dived into radical
gender theory in pre-k so then what's
happening once we get a few years down
the line let's listen
by second grade we move on explicitly to
gender identity and talk about it again
in terms of your head and your heart and
your body parts matching up and does
that work for you
what happens if it doesn't what are the
other parts of you that have to do with
your gender identity and what are the
parts of you that don't and the kids
draw wonderful self-portraits again
but dealing with all aspects of their
identity including specifically their
gender
okay so that's second grade now before
we talk about that i want to play one
more clip for you
because we go through you know pre-k
kindergarten first grade second grade
then they go third fourth fifth and we
get up to fifth grade
and uh and listen to what's happening by
the time we get to fifth grade and
beyond
starting in fifth grade we start using
the words for that that sex
is
what you were born with
it's external and internal genitalia
it's hormones and
chromosomes um
that's
something that you can only change with
a whole lot of effort um
gender identity is how you feel inside
it's what you feel like in your heart
and in your head just like the language
that we used when they were younger but
it's something personal it's something
that's unique to you it's something that
you get to decide gender expression is
what you share with the world
how you dress how you act what you're
interested in what you put out there and
that again is your choice it's something
that you can change from day to day it's
completely up to you
sexual orientation
is who you are emotionally and
physically attracted to and so
that's how we talk about it with the
kids and introduce them to it fifth
grade is our big year it's
not that all of them aren't
but we do the reproductive system
and puberty
the we
talk about gender identity specifically
with the gender unicorn this time
talking about things as a continuum
um
for gender identity and expression sex
assigned at birth who you're physically
attracted to and who you're emotionally
attracted to so all those aspects of
gender identity and sexuality and we do
read a book it the kids are like you're
reading us a storybook we're in fifth
grade
but it does a lovely job of talking
about gender identity
the gender unicorn
now they've been using this thing for
years and it hasn't gotten any more
sophisticated or coherent over time on
the gender unicorn chart the kids are
told that there are five spectrums not
just one
gender identity gender expression sex
you're which is also a spectrum now um
your physical attraction and your
emotional attraction so we're drawing a
distinction there and these are all
supposed to be distinct and lucid
categories on their own of course in
reality in practice they're not
these become at best different vaguely
defined pockets of confusion none of
this helps the kids better understand
themselves
no kid is looking at the gender unicorn
chart and say oh i unders okay i get it
now
it has exactly the opposite effect which
is intended all of this is about
deconstructing the child's identity
unpersoning them taking away everything
that's solid and real and true and
distinct and unique
infecting them with a lifelong identity
crisis
but notice something else
we've heard the uh the quote-unquote
queer curriculum
from pre-k all the way to fifth grade
now the lessons and the language don't
really change at all during that time
it's not as though the kids are
introduced to the concept of gender
identity and then are taken deeper into
it introduced to increasingly complex
aspects of it
the way that we do with a subject like
writing or you know mathematics
now instead it's repetition like a
religious creed
the same basic concept repeated over and
over and over and over again
and as they get into college and alleged
adulthood
it doesn't change
you can enroll in a gender studies
program in an ivy league school
and you'll be hearing the same slogan
sex is your body and your gender
identity is how you feel inside
it's literally the same thing that they
tell preschoolers
at no point at any age at any level is
is this idea actually explained in a way
that makes sense
because it doesn't make sense
instead the slogan is is related over
and over and over again
and that's because all of this stuff is
vapid and shallow
and goes no deeper than a puddle of piss
on the bathroom floor
and that's why they want to get to the
kids as early as possible so that they
can be fully invested in it fully
inducted into the cult
before they're old enough to ask even
the most basic questions
because none of this can withstand even
the most basic questions
and of course underlying all of this
and all these efforts
is this immense inordinate sense of
entitlement
by the education system generally and
especially among the queer activists
within it
they believe that they're owed your
children's hearts minds and souls
that's a ransom that you're supposed to
pay them they believe
it's what they're entitled to
hand your children over they say
and let the groomers do as they wish
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated